[Applause]
oh good to be here um
helping my buddy move yesterday just
gonna put the rest of the stuff
up on craigslist
anybody been to this website
it looks like it came out when the
internet came out
but you want to put up some flash
looks like braille i mean
and i don't know why people are doing
this what are you out of your mind
you're gonna put up a couch for 23
dollars
and you're gonna wait for someone to
come murder you
and your entire family
just put it right area rug for sale come
stab
me and the neighborhood i mean
i don't know i grew up in an italian
family we don't trust
nobody okay
we had a garage sale growing up we were
we were nervous to even do that
we had a meeting you know you want to
have this sale yeah we'll try it right
and we just threw the garbage
out on the driveway put a couple signs
all over the neighborhood
come get our garbage
and the weirdest people would show up at
the house
they'd be waiting in the street
[Laughter]
and you just watch this dysfunction
happen all over your property
right they look at your stuff
and some of them a little too close
they'd come a little too close to the
house
you'd have to tell them hey back up back
up back up ask me from there what you
want i got
kids here
can we share bathroom bathroom get off
the property
it's not walmart you pick it and go back
to the cave you crawled out
and whatever we didn't sell we threw it
out
but we broke it before we put it in the
garbage
it's my italian fathers like if they're
not gonna buy it at my sale
they're not gonna come by later and
steal it out of that garbage
saw the couch in half why
he had a whole thing he's like you know
burn the lamps
pop the eyeballs out of this teddy bear
and then decapitate the head
sort of head out on monday and then the
body out on saturday
peace it out over the week
the world's changing i don't think it's
for the better
everybody's walking around tattoos body
art what's it
guys will do it a lot they'll get one
right on the bicep
now every shirt becomes a sleeveless
they gotta billboard the tattoo
because there's like a special meaning
behind it you'll get some idiot that
comes up to the guy
excuse me what's the significance
why do you have a cobra head on your
bike
the guy gets all emotional he's like
thanks for asking
what it is it's a cobra head and the
reason i got it
my father got bit by a snake okay
it's not done yet it's never done they
got to go back right
2025 i'm gonna have the entire snake all
over my body
but for now it's just ahead but what's
gonna happen it's gonna come across
my chest cascade down my torso
the tail is gonna wrap around my nut bag
oh don't laugh it's for my dad
it's going to creep around my back the
rattle's going to take up my nipple
[Applause]
out of my nipple it's going to say dad
rest in peace you know
what the hell are you doing to yourself
what did you forget he died what do you
look down
oh yeah
people ask me all the time sebastian why
don't you have it
too why i don't put bumper stickers on
ferraris
that's my time yeah